Seville in 1519. Their cap as Magellan, Portuguese in the service of the Spanish King Charles V.
Their destination, well more of a mission, is to sail around the world.
What world? Nobody's quite sure. It's agreed that the world is round, so why prove it again?
Poor Don Juan de Cartagena. Your Excellencies, the King's officers.
For me, wait, wait, it's long.
Oh, September 10th, 1519, heading for...
Oh, not used as a lifeline.
September 10th, 1519, we set our course, heading for, uh...
2nd of November, the fleet came in sight of the northeastern coast of Brazil.
Had they finally found the passage to the west?
No, it was only the delta of the Rio de la Plata.
201520, the passage is finally discovered.
A strait, which from then on would be called the Straits of Magellan.
But during the voyage, a mutiny had to be put down, and one of the ships, the Santiago, ran onto the rocks.
But finally, there were the crew and officers looking off into a peaceful sea, the Pacific Ocean.
We needn't go into the troubles that they had. We'll stick to our subject.
Now, four months later, they visit the Robber's Island. It's a good name for the place.
1521, while taking part in an action to help a friendly king, Magellan is killed in battle.
As compensation, the friendly king has the ship's officers massacred.
September 4th, 1522, more than three years after setting out of Seville,
with 265 men and five ships heading west,
Delcano, one of Magellan's lieutenants, returns.
But from the east, and with only 18 men, the earth is round.
1818, a year before Magellan will sail.
We are on the other side of the Atlantic at Santiago de Cuba.
26 years after Columbus, Santiago has become the port
from which the Spanish explorers were to venture into the new continent.
Governor Velazquez, who had been a friend of Columbus, is unhappy.
No, and no, that's not how we shall build a worthy empire for His Majesty.
Criada, my nephew, who are a nincompoop, understand?
There were so many Indians, most of them heavily armed.
What could we do?
Use your crossbows.
You didn't show much courage, nephew.
Courageous around here, a man who wouldn't be afraid of Indians.
Hernando Cortes, nephew, go out and find him, then bring him here.
Hernando Cortes, I name you captain. You shall have men, ships, and provisions. And weapons. Write that down.
Yes, write it down. Easy to say, Rex. No more ink.
Meanwhile, in Tenochtitlan, today Mexico City, sat the great Montezuma in his palace.
No one was allowed to look him in the face.
Great Montezuma, strange things are happening.
As predicted, white men are coming from the sea in great towers that float upon the sea.
Just as the prediction had predicted the great white god, Quetzalcoatl.
And he will come from the rising sun, that is, from the east.
They could be enemies.
Many carry big sticks making fire and thunder.
All these visitors are now gone, they tell me.
Let us keep watch.
Tell me if any return.
I'm pleased that you are with us, Bernal Diaz.
You're a cultured man.
You will tell the story of our adventures.
I promise they will be worth telling.
A good ship.
But we shall need others.
And many men.
We'll be heading for populated lands.
And these powerful lands are probably rich, captain, very rich.
Bernal, I want you to put out a proclamation.
Sandslave said land, pacified of cool soldiers, it's your chance to volunteer.
Plenty of gold to be had.
Yeah, what's the good of rotten here? Let's go.
Give us a d-
Sweet sample, am I in?
Splendid demonstration, I'll take him.
Hum, little pig, me, me, who discovered the West Indies with Columbus?
Dozens and dozens of-
this hernando cortez is ambitious i wonder if i was wrong can i trust him or not sailed away
already that's right cortez had a hunch that the governor might change his mind and so he
weighed anchor at dawn and sailed away it is on november 18 1518 at the age of 34 venturing off
to make conquests with 500 soldiers 110 sailors 200 indians 14 cannon 16 horses and before him an
an immense unknown empire.
Mexico.
Amigos, amigos, por aquí, por aquí.
You speak Spanish.
Yes, I am as Spanish as you are.
I am Aguilar.
Balboa, I was with him.
But our ship sank, and that was eight years ago.
Yes, but I'm afraid I'm the only survivor.
I'm well acquainted with the land, and I speak the language.
You are welcome to join us.
From today, you will serve as our interpreter.
But first, I will have to cut your hair
so you look like a Spaniard.
No, no, no, no, not that too short.
I suppose we came to a compromise.
Not the beard, not the beard.
They're Mayas, and the city Tabasco is just down the road.
They say don't go any farther, that's what they said.
Tell them we come in peace.
We are here to speak of God and His Majesty the King, and we have gifts.
Oh yes, we have brought worthless trinkets.
But they can give us gold if they want.
As it happens, they aren't exactly alone.
Drugs, gentlemen!
They say if you take one step, they'll attack with all their men.
Tell them we'll be back tomorrow.
we're prepared for combat tell them to think it over session this land in the name of his majesty
the king of spain any who oppose this will meet the challenge of my sword
angry at that and peace but only on one condition they do what they're told
wants only to maintain the peace and he gives us slaves to serve us
this attractive girl is of noble blood she is malinsine but it is not only
mayan that she speaks also aztec which i do not so we can communicate with the entire country tell
him we will treat her with respect we will baptize her and call her donna marina and now chief let's
see some gold someplace it has for gold there was no lack of it here and montezuma hoped that by
giving presents he would be in the good graces of the newcomer our emperor presents you with these
gifts great master but requests with respect that you go no farther thank the emperor for his gifts
we appreciate them and kindly inform him we go to the west my master orders it your master but
how could it be anyway if you advance we will reply with the might of our modest cortez was
well informed green gems for mexicans were stones of destiny ornaments of gods well he was clever
that way but he was lucky too he was facing a great empire waiting for a god only it was an
empire for all its size barely held together there were plenty of cracks which cortez turned to his
advantage. Fat cacique, he welcomes you. He knows that you are an all-powerful lord, and he implores
your help. His people, the Totonaca, are under the tyranny of the Aztec King Montezuma. Every
year his emissaries come looking for the best young people, and they're sacrificed, and they're made
into slaves. Can you help him? He was sobbing. We were deeply moved, Cortez and everyone. Tell him
we offer to be friends of the Totonac people.
He will suffer this no longer.
They'll be under our protection.
And you agreed to give them
20 of your young men and 20 girls
for sacrifice?
Really, he wasn't given much choice.
Now you are under the protection of King Charles
of Spain. You should refuse better yet.
You must imprison
this is what we're going to do.
A splendid idea, Excellency.
So, Bernal, we'll have no more human sacrifices, follow me!
Move, Pedro!
...of statues, which were half man and half, and of immense size.
When they saw them break into tiny pieces, the cacique and his priests were afraid.
Captain, there are rumors of revolt.
We've lost 35 men in three months. They want to return to Santiago.
It's to Mexico City that we go!
the men will refuse excellency very well then i will hang them that all our ships be sunk and
the traitors were punished since with no boats we have no choice we shall go forward to conquer
this land but all of us will perish here it is better to die live without honor then glory is
awaiting us right here the gold of mexico is off sandoval you will stay here with a hundred men to
God already. You follow me forward your city. With an audacity unparalleled in history,
Captain Cortez burnt his boats behind him. In August 1519, he sets off to conquer a vast empire.
He had 400 men, 16 horses, 7 cannon, 1,000 Tontonac warriors as escorts, and 1,000 porters.
Facing him, hundreds of thousands of Aztec warriors. Oh yes. Repeat after me.
This is a hand. This is my sword. That's it. This is my nose, but that is yours.
My nose. This is your nose.
Klaxcara. Only who can pronounce this name? I mean, it's Klaxcala.
It is a city with many warriors, but bad. With Aztecs, they are not friendly.
We'll beat all of them and their allies.
Under the command of the valiant Zikotenga the Younger, the battle was ferocious.
We buried our dead in secret to maintain the legend of our immortality.
But after four days, we...
His name's Tico Tenga, and he's commander of the army.
He says you may well be white god. Disimpress him.
He invite white god to come to city.
You speak. Chief's people are oppressed by the terrible chief Montezuma.
He will be ally. Give many thousand warrior men, if you come and lead them.
We'll be happy to accept this alliance.
With our weapons and with his men, I'll lead the people to victory.
Just what I was hoping.
Now, with that many men, it's possible to conquer Mexico City.
Oh yes, now Cortez was commander of thousands of Tlaxcaltec warriors and on they marched toward Mexico City.
The city of Cholula was on their route with its 400 temples and pyramids higher than those in Egypt.
Everything seemed peaceful, but Cortez had been warned they were plotting a massacre and ordered the attack.
From then on, the Spanish troops were to meet no more resistance.
1,500 meters. I want volunteers to climb it.
And come back with observations.
Diego de Hordas. Who else?
The city.
Isn't it remarkable?
Capital of the Aztec Empire.